bonjour 7e et votre conseiller koffi
frappe
on parle souvent de taux à 2% à 4% voire
12%
mais peut-on parler de pourcentage
lorsqu'on parle de liberté financière
faut en effet avec notre livret blanc la
solution est simple et efficace et à
toto retard que tu es j'ai pas fini mon
annonce
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui peut de fait
resté un tube quoi tu veux une meuf à
poil j'ai pas de me faut par contre j'ai
un super bon bleus il est lu l'un non
attends alors ok la meuf à poil j'allais
mettre à poil dans les dom on parle
souvent de 3 2% 4 % voire 12%
peut-on vraiment parler de pourcentage
lorsqu'on parle de liberté financière
non mais mes atouts mais c'est quoi ton
truc
qu'est ce tu veux je ne sais pas d'où tu
veux de la chanson peut-être du cadre et
de la chanson française j'ai cadré de
chagrin cavale et des gâteaux
[Musique]
majid des figurines de papier dans les
corridors aux pierres s'est pas vraiment
cabrel non mais attends tu veux quoi tu
je sais pas moi tu un chaton peut-être
un panier de chatons mais tenus par
norman normal alors peut-on parler de
liberté financière lorsque l'on veut
parler de pourcentage
faux [__] tu veux quoi tu veux ma mère
c'est ça tu veux la guerre tu que je
bute ma mère touche pas la gueule 1
alors évidemment on peut parler de
liberté financière comment de paris nice
1 2 2% des 4 % alors écoute moi bien
hein parce que moi je ne bute en a rien
à branler nous regarde ton sketch la de
merde etc les perruques etc
non le regardant pense au mec que tu
viens d'ignorer
est ce que ce monde est sérieux
[Musique]
dis-lui mardi matin ils raccrochent
jeudi matin hier j'étais avec une fille
je les torcher tu as couché avec elle
non je les justes torché
[Musique]
caillé portée